good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 2020
[Music]
euclid exactly special containment
procedures scp-2029 a type 4 humanoid
containment cell at site 17 standard
amenities and precautions associated
with tee for HCC are in place dietary
supplement 2020 - 9 consisting of 1.4
kilograms of used shredded paper is to
be provided daily SCP 2027 are any
unusual activity with all vocalizations
transcribed 128 grams of tissue samples
from SCP 2020
is Evan teen access to SCP 2024 its
biological samples are to be approved by
the head of scp-2029 team enoyed entity
approximately 2.2 meters in height and
70 kilograms in mass SCP 2020 possesses
unusually long and thin limbs as well as
facial features commonly associated with
Ray aliens see file photo and bright
green coloration SCP 20 24 month that
appears to serve skeletal muscular
circulatory and endocrine functions SCP
2020 census tum' and nutritional
requirements are consistent with its
diet which consists entirely of paper
and water
scp-2029 shown any signs of growth or
aging since recovery further study of
scp-2029 as' and resistance to tearing
which renders standard methodologies
ineffective as well as its dissimilarity
to terrestrial biology
SCP 2020 claims to originate from a
technologically advanced
extraterrestrial civilization but will
make wildly different claims regarding
the nature and location of this
civilization when questioned given the
circumstances of SCP 2023 the document
Belen can Roswell 2020 this avenue of
research is nonetheless considered
viable SCP 2020s behavior suggests that
it shares many psychological
similarities with humans such as the
ability to learn a desire for
interaction and partial understanding of
social norms it is fluent in English and
response to the names Artie Bobby and
Izzy it is not engaged in hostile
behavior and appears indifferent to its
own containment SCP 2020 will frequently
attempt to engage personnel in
conversations regarding its desire to
write science fiction and numerous ideas
it has for science fiction stories it
has thus far failed to produce any
actual writing citing an inability to
choose a concept see attached transcript
for details
addendum excerpt from interview 2021 AAS
Oh SCP 2020 was permitted to speak to
researcher King on any topic and wished
facility right it was made by someone at
some time in the past - to bring the
whole world back from the apocalypse
like something could blow a hole in the
earth and the facility went game over
play again by slashing that hole could
just be the Marianas Trench because the
facility can do pretty much anything
with physics and technology how exactly
this fits into a story or anything but I
mean it could be the setting I think I
guess I can think guys guys I have
another idea
forget about this one this one is a
brain in a jar
there's a guy please shake right but
later
here is that I just run with it crazy
Nutty Professor time not inventions that
don't work complete nonsense but it's
all working guys die and his inventions
could be like in our superhero or
something
Johnny vacuum brain in a jar with germs
that sounds wrong I'll think of
something it's okay though because I
just got this awesome idea there's a
wizard wait for it from space a space
what is it guys that's not the only
bother here's a sidewalk and he's with
five with five bad girls and guess where
the twist is that's right
with cat girls also cyborgs and they
fight crime cliche right I mean but it's
not because they're fighting space crime
crime in space does that make sense
guys the spory would be about them being
cyborgs and fighting crime actually no
because I just got a better idea
wait it's an AI right an artificial
intelligence on a computer cliche right
well it makes simulations of the perfect
world for that person and then and then
it's their brains it hikes but maybe
it's not actually doing that and I I
guess the characters don't know for sure
that it's actually doing that because we
can't see inside it but here's a plot to
us there if then puts a fake brain in
them and makes the bodies convince other
people to go into the simulation it's a
horror story or a sci-fi horror story
science Horror Story wait guys here's
another idea for you I I just got this
idea there's a time machine right and it
sends people to the future and then back
to the present and in the future
in the future everyone dies from an
asteroid not everyone just enough people
that it's like everyone cliche right
well the main characters or I guess it
could be the villains or villain
protagonists they're trying to make sure
that a future happens guys that's
because every time they try to look at
another future if that future is even
worse because involves actually everyone
dying except for one time where it's
like a who wants to live forever deal I
know what the actual story is then I'll
think of something okay wait but
seriously better idea guys there's this
alien right like they have in the movies
with the green skin and the black eyes
in everything cliche right wait and for
whatever reason I'll think of that later
it really wants to become a science
fiction writer but it can't stop coming
up with ideas long enough to do it
and the twist is the twist is that it's
talking to some people and they're from
a government agency that already has all
the things it's talking about and
they're like how does it know this stuff
and does it even know it's all real
right well the way we await two words
just two words laser but disease wait
wait guys that was actually three that
was three words this is going to be a
lot harder than I thought
all right I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening and
you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre Bichette Pierce M
Hamlin Muslim Wookiee Jax Merrick Caleb
Bowen slump God John Porter
captain Gorge Tiber ball Cody tench
cheese whip dips McGee on dr. mortis
thank you so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you